because I'm saying to you that I'm in a
relationship and I've been on a date
you're not interested in that no because
you're saying you're a traditional woman
so I know that's not the fact I'm gonna
be a traditional woman I'm not married
I'm having sex regular is that
traditional I thought you were
traditional sorry I can't be no no no no
no no no sorry okay don't confuse
traditional at all I would not say that
I'd say that I'm old
okay
no I'm not traditional I'm not married
how can I be traditional I'm having sex
outside of marriage how can I be
traditional okay because when you was a
traditional word means that you have sex
in a marriage and that you're married
that's traditional so don't get confused
you can behave traditional I might
behave traditional okay but I'm not
traditional sorry and I'm not hypocrite
either no my apologies only because
obviously when you were saying being a
traditional woman is better whatever I
thought you were no no I was asking you
because of the when you said about the
modern and the tradition okay because
you stand a dance of being traditional
because you're married but as far as I'm
concerned when you're not married when
you get divorced and you move on you're
not traditional no more that's the
difference between you and me you've got
a chance to be traditional because
you've got a ring if you get divorced
now in my view you're not traditional
anymore because you're divorced so
between you and me I would say
Traditional Values doesn't make you
traditional
can you be traditional again even after
a divorce get married again will you
then no traditional is you're a virgin
and then you get married okay that's
that's traditional if you didn't do that
you're not traditional okay now I'm not
traditional I have Traditional Values as
in I prefer like old school I don't like
all you know the dating apps and stuff
like that I personally don't do them but
I wouldn't be able to say I am
traditional because I've had sex out of
wedlock I've had kids out of wedlock you
know Dad I am I have a very modern life
but I just deep down it's when it comes
to love and stuff like that and values
it's you know what our parents grew up
with our grandpa Foundation yeah like
you know back in the 1900s whatever
1940s 1950s before
foreign
for the ladies actually
if a guy had everything you wanted could
you look past him stepping out from time
to time
not not another wife not another like
Main Chick just like hoes here and there
no
no this one I don't know I don't know
that's just an easy yes no it's not easy
to weigh up what what options you would
have because yeah he might be cheating
every now and then of course you don't
want that you want him to be with you
but you have everything you want but
also getting everything you want should
you then sacrifice happiness that is
cheating on you you know wouldn't you
either be with someone that isn't
cheating on you and maybe gives you some
things you want and then you work the
for the other things you want yourself
see I would rather have my partner have
a full partner than have women who's
just the question
yeah no I wouldn't you wouldn't do that
I wouldn't respect that okay what about
you two
I think I did not like
seeing in this day and age yeah I feel
like the there really is no [ __ ]
thing is whether a man has money whether
he has a Porsche whether he has whatever
he's gonna cheat that's the like if I'd
be lying to myself if I said to this
question that I was gonna say you know
oh no I'd rather have a man that doesn't
cheat because if I go to the man that I
think doesn't cheat he's gonna cheat as
well so they all cheat that's the
realest like that oh this fairy tale
[ __ ] it's not real
it's very rare it's like 0.011
yeah but like is it it on his generation
she's she's that bit older where it
makes that difference you get it in our
generation I'm 23 I was born in 1999
yeah it's I it's very very very rare
that I'm gonna find a man
it's not it's not rare one out of three
men are virgins or haven't had sex in
the past year it's just it's just the
men of women no it's it's where like
what place is the study from as in the
one in three guys like is it just in
England or is it the whole I think the
BBC did that study you know I I don't
remember off the top but there's a very
different place yeah but don't give a
rug it doesn't get better outside of
London can I just say I would I would I
would I would argue that that in London
it's the same you're in a big city
hypergamy is the thing can I like I
think when people have more options like
women sleep with a smaller and smaller
percentage of guys when they have more
access yeah but like like uh in the
countryside the men are a lot more
traditional women are a lot more like
it's I've come from Lincolnshire and I
can promise you now is 10 times worse
it's not even City Center like we're out
by the seaside or you can be out in the
sticks like middle of nowhere it is so
bad over there yeah I don't I don't
necessarily like think all men she like
my dad's like top one percent earner he
never cheated on my mom it's there but
like I I just think it's it's rare and
so like you kind of have to be realistic
with what your like values are and
especially if you want a guy that's like
really good looking and gets girls like
can I just say this can I just say this
I just want to say this one thing no one
here other than Auntie maybe Eddie just
about myself just about has the life
experience to say that all men cheat
because you're 23 when you're 23 you've
hardly lived an adult life I think that
I've never been this year but I'm saying
for my generation yeah but do you get it
yeah I do okay but you're 23 that's the
thing so to say that all men cheat at 23
it's like you're setting yourself up
just not selling myself a dream and can
I just say that
when Paul asked that question
she said if a man had everything that
you want yeah straight away people think
about money yeah yeah yeah none of that
thought about you know I'm thinking can
you fix the sink
can you wear a plug
that's why I was thinking that I can do
it at myself that's the realistic
Ally
you know what I can do it
but there's plumbers no but the first
thing I actually thought was is that
everything I want you see the cheating
part is that something I want no way
the cheating part is that something I
want to answer is no okay what are the
things that I want in a man these
attributes that I like in a man
Direction the way of thinking the way of
leading these things are rare in men
anyway so I know in myself if I find a
man like that and he cheats I'm not
gonna be feeling it but who knows I
might just yeah you know
I just because but
I will say this wouldn't like what
Auntie said when Paul asked that
question a lot of people think of
materialistic things and that's the
point isn't it what can you buy me is he
giving me a nice house is he giving me
um the ability to spend my money is he
giving me Financial Freedom without me
working for it is he fulfilling my
entitlement I understand that's not
obviously it's come across I've said
Porsche this stuff no not you no just in
general like the generation in general
it is always straight away money but
like see see me as personally I make my
own money I've got my own car do you
have all these things that a man I'm
asking for I've got myself yeah it's not
like I'm drunk now I stay at home and
I'm bummed out claim Universal Credit
and I'm asking for a man with a [ __ ]
Ferrari yeah not at all I've got all
this [ __ ] myself so why is it that you
know I can't ask for a man with the same
level as me as well as I feel like it
goes without set like why do I have to
say I want love from a man in a
relationship I feel like actually go
without saying all these attributes
that's that's like loyalty that is a
relationship isn't it trust loyalty but
it's like the bare minimum yeah like why
should I have to ask for that because
the stat you don't the standard has been
the standard has been changed the
standard the standard has been changed
and outlined by younger generation of
women that the standard is you have to
have materialistic things and this is
what happens men adjust themselves to
accommodate the women in society because
their biological response is to breed
women get bbos and surgery for men to
look at them but they'll say it's for
them and the men no because they did it
because you were a guy's attention
you're playing into a man's biology but
then you're angry when a man talks to
you that you don't like right so if it
was Drake or whoever you would be happy
but if it's the average guy down the
road driving her I don't know what or
riding a bike it's not for you you know
what because of that yeah
and I truly believe now I've changed my
mind here yeah most women today want to
be cheated on I'm running with that no
I'm running with that I'm running with
that because because what literally sit
in here and listening to what women say
now about
it would you accept a guy that wouldn't
cheat on you but all thinking about
materialistic things Etc there is pure
men that would that make money burying
them out as Tech nerds that these guys
caught money here but they might not
have to Alpha and yeah stuff like that
but you really these guys don't even
register on your writ to school you
can't even see them but then you want to
go for the guy who you know is going to
have bad girl on him who you know is
going to cheat on you but for some
reason you're the special one is going
to stay loyal to you that is just pure
delusion you want to be cheated
yesterday
yeah
expect it that's what I'm saying like
like we can't say we don't like it if we
we pick these guys because there's guys
that won't do it but we don't pick them
and and I say this because I've talked
to hunt probably what hundreds of women
at this point and the amount that have a
toxic X
it's like all of them everyone's got one
and it's like
yeah
that's what they say I'm thinking about
it I think the balance comes into play
with the tech and the nerds or whatever
they don't even have the confidence to
talk to women and they're not in the
form is that because we've made them
feel like that
I was just gonna say I was just gonna
say in this Society we we reward bad
behavior